[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا الكرام انا طاهر بركي
وهذه العربيه 360 حيث الخبر من كل زواياها
ومن جميع جوانبه
لنقل السيطره بمناطقها في سوريا الى دمشق
والاكراد يستنفرون
يرحبوا بالتعاون مع حكومه نتنياهو لكن
يقول انه سيرفض اي سياسات تعارض حل
الدولتين
قيود طالبان تعرض الجامعات الافغانيه لقطر
الافلاس والاغلاق وتهدد الملايين بالجوع
وفي العربيه 360 ايضا
تحقيقات تكشف كيف استولى باكمان فرايد على
546 مليون دولار من بورصه العملات المشفره
اكس اكس
[موسيقى]
نذكر بالخبر العاجل كما قلنا قبل قليل
وفاه اسطوره كره القدم العالميه
البرازيليه بيليه اذا ياتي ذلك بعد معاناه
طويله مع المرض تبعنا كلنا في الايام
الاخيره اييه حجم ما وصل اليه تمكن المرض
منه وهو في سريره في ساعته وايامه الاخيره
وبطبيعه الحال الكل سيكون انظاره في
العالم على هذا الخبر الان خبر وفاه
نجم كره القدم البرازيليه اسطوره كره
القدم
العالميه وبطبيعه الحال الكل من مسؤولين
من من كبار قاعده اللعبه في العالم من
المسؤولين المعنيين بهذا الموضوع همم
الهواه من
المحبين من متابعي الاسطوره يعني يتواف
على تشييعه بكلاما وايضا على ارض الواقع
خاصه على وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي نحن
سنتابع هذا الخبر عندما تبدا ردود الافعال
حوله ولكن نبدا اولا بملفنا الاول في هذا
الموضوع وهو التطبيع الوشيك الذي تتجه
انقره ودمشق نحوه هو مسار بدا منذ اشهر
وتوج امس بلقاء جماعه وزراء دفاع البلدين
وروسيا في موسكو اليوم اعلنت انقره نيتها
نقل السيطره بمناطق وجود القوات التركيه
في سوريا الى دمشق حاله حققي لاستقرار
السياسي مشيره الى امكانيه العمل المشترك
مستقبل مع دمشق لمكافحه الارهاب وزير
الخارجيه التركي مولود شاوش اوبروه وفي
كلمه خلال اجتماع تقييم نهايه العام قال
ان تركيا تؤكد مرارا عزمها نقل السيطره في
مناطق تواجدها حاليا الى سوريا حاله تحقيق
الاستقرار السياسي وعوده الامور الى
طبيعتها
بلاد تشاوش اوغلو ايضا اعتبر انه من
المهمه اشراك النظام الدولي والامم
المتحده ايضا في موضوع عوده اللاجئين
السوريين
[موسيقى]
اذا نتابع واياكم هذه الصور التي تصلنا
الى لحظه وفاه اسطوره كره القدم
البرازيليه بيليه طبعا وكاله الانباء بدات
بعرض كل تفاصيل مراحل حياته واهم محطاته
الكرويه في العالم الرياضيه اذا وكالات
الانباء تورد الان خبر وفاه اسطوره كره
القدم البرازيليه بيليه وهذه الصور من
محطاته طبعا هناك الكثير من يعني
المعلومات المهمه عن تاريخها كمحترف سابق
ويعتبر احد اعظم اللاعبين في كل العصور
يصنفه الاتحاد الدولي لكره القدم
بالاعظم وكان من بين اكثر الشخصيات طبعا
نجاحا وشعبيه في هذه اللعبه في القرن ال
20 في عام 99 تم تسميته برياضي القرن من
قبل اللجنه الاولمبيه الدوليه
ما ادراجه ايضا في قائمه التاينز الاهم
لمئه شخصيه في القرن ال 20 لاهم 100 شخصيه
في القرن العشرين تم التصويت على بيليه
ايضا افك افضل لاعب في العالم من قبل
الاتحاد الدولي لتاريخ واحصاء كره القدم
وكان احد الفائزين
بالمشتركين بجائزه لاعب القرن من فيفا تم
الاعتراف له بالف
279 هدفا في
1363 مباراه لاعبها بما في ذلك المباريات
الوديه كارقام قياسيه في موسوعه غينيس
اديسونسينتو وهو بيليه الذي يتوفى اليوم
التاسع والعشرين من ديسمبر من عام 2022 عن
عمر نهز 82 عاما وقد ولد في الثالث
والعشرين من اكتوبر من عام 1940
يتوفى بعدما سجل نفسه اسطوره في تاريخ
المهاجمين الرياضيين العالميين وهو اييي
البرازيلي الجوهره السوداء تتنحى تترجى
اليوم عن عالم الرياضه
وابنته تقول الان نحبك بلا حدود ارقد
بسلام ابنه اسطوره كره القدم البرازيليه
تقول على انستقرام الان نحبك بلا حدود
وارقد بسلام طبعا الكثير من التعليقات
التي ستاتي ومن ردود الافعال حول تاريخ
حول المسؤولين الذين تعاملوا معه خاصه في
الشقه الرياضي ونحن سنتحدث ايضا في هذا
الموضوع الى بعض المتابعين الرياضيين
والخبراء الرياضيين حول هذا الموضوع
وهذه الصور لا تزال تريدنا الان
لكل الجوائز التي همم ربحها او فاز بها
بيليه ونحن هنا في نظره على ساو باولو حيث
الصحافه البرازيليه والعالميه بدون شك
كلها اعينها وانظارها على هذا الموضوع وكل
تغطياتها الان على هذا الموضوع كما نشاهد
الصحفيين وهم يتجمعون هناك صحفي رياضي
خالد خطاطبه الينا الان للحديث عن هذا
الموضوع كيف تتلقى كصحف في رياض خبر وفاه
اسطوره كره القدم البرازيلي
مساء الخير لحضرتك ولا استاذه للمشاهدين
يعني هو خبر حزين وفاه اسطوره كرويه
عالميه تحدث به للاجيال
وما يزالته لغايه الان رغم وجود النجوم
العالميين امثاله رونالدو وميسي ونيمار
الا ان الملاعب يعني حقيقه لم تنجب لاعب
بمثل هذه الموهبه
الراحل بليه يعتبر رمز من رموز كره القدم
العالميه هذا اللاعب الذي قدم الكثير
الكثير لكره القدم الاردنيه وما زال مساء
لكل لاعب يهوى كره القدم ويعشق هذه
الساحره المستديره ما ابرز ما كان يميز
بيليه عن غيره همم بين همم رواد جيلو من
اقرانه في اللعبه
ان كان بحياته الشخصيه او بصفاته او
باسلوب لعبوا حتى
هو لاعب يعني يكفي انه حقق انجازات غير
مسبوقه للمنتخب البرازيلي بنحكي عن كاس
العالم هذا اللاعب يعني هو الذي احضر او
فاز بكاس العالم للبرازيل لاعب بمواصفات
صعب انه تتكرر في الملاعب العالميه لاعب
بيمتاز بالمهارات الفنيه اضافه الى
تعامله وهو كان لاعب قياده في المنتخب
البرازيلي عندما تلتقي اساطير كره القدم
البرازيليه همم الذين لعبوا في جيل هذا
اللاعب يتحدثون عن قيادته عن كيفيه
التعامل مع مع اللاعبين وهو بمثابه بمثابه
المدرب في الملعب يعني كل اللاعبين اللي
عاطروا بالليل بعتبروه هو مدرب في الملعب
لاخر
لا اعتقد لا اعتقد هي يمكن ظروف كره القدم
نعم الان قواته بنحكي عن
اساليب جديده بنحكي عن اسلوب لعبه جديده
عن عن لاعبين امثال ميسي ورونالدو لكن انا
باعتقادي انه الملاعب العالميه لغايه الان
لم تنجب لاعب متكامل لاعب مهاري ولاعب
قيادي ولاعب يتمتع بالخلق بدليل انه قبل
شويه طلع خبر وفاه همم
[موسيقى]
البرازيليه كل اللاعبين يعني انا متابع
للتغريدات اللي تكتب من قبل النجوم كره
القدم العالميه سواء حتى في الارجنتين
اللي يعني تعتبر منافس منافس شرس للمنتخب
البرازيلي الكل في هذا اللاعب في عام
واحده 60 حكومه البرازيل اعلنت همم كنز
وطني رسمي همم لمنعه من الانتقال الى خارج
البلاد بعد ما كان استدعي للاعب مع
المنتخب البرازيلي ده وفي سن همم
اه جدا همم طبعا اضافه الى همم الكلمه او
المصطلح الذي اشتهر به عندما يتحدث عن
اللعبه الجميله همم عباره اللعبه الجميله
التي اقرمها بالكره القدم دائما مع غزاره
اهداف اللي كان معروف فيها استاذ خطاطبه
معناته هو جوهره
يعني كنجم كاسطوره كمثال كقد ولا لكل
اللاعبين
حتى همم اثناء مونديال قطر 20 22 لما كان
بيليه دخل المستشفى شفنا كميه التعاطف معه
من جماهير ال- ال- الكره البرازيليه بشكل
خاص وجمهور العالم بشكل عام فاا لما
يتعاطف معك الخصم خصم اللدود دائما لما
يتعاطف معك في مثل هذه الحاله ف- ف- همم
فليعرف العالم منه هذا هو جوهره وهذا
اسطوره خبر يعني خبر حزين لكل العالم ليس
فقط في البرازيل وحتى ليس
فقط في جمهور كره القدم في العالم هو امتد
له كل القطاع الثقافيه والرياضيه
والسياسيه لكل بنعها هذا اللاعب فا مجرد
هذا نشوف هذا المشهد فهذا دليل على انه
فعلا هو همم اسطوره رحل راح يخسر العالم
كثير بيبي رحيل هذا الجوهره واعتقد انه
البرازيل راح اتكرر هذا اللاعب من خلال
كثير من التسميات على البطولات وعلى
الملاعب وايضا راح يكون له صدى في كل
العالم معنا حمزه ادريس اللاعب السعودي
السابق اهلا بك همم معنا حمزه الان ااه
كيف تصف لنا مشاعرك لاعب همم سابق عندما
تسمع خبر وفاه بلي
همم نكون صراحه وخبر حزين لاي واحد يعشق
كره القدم
اسطوره او حيضل اسطوره كبيره في عالم كره
القدم
وفاته خبر
محزن تعازيل العائلات والعشاق على مستوى
العالم كله يعني واحد من اساطير كره القدم
نحن تعلمنا يمكن ما لحقنا نشوف ولكن سيرته
للام باقيه وهذا يدل على ما قدموا لعالم
كره القدم كمدرسه
يمكن بناء من اهم الاشياء اللي اسسها كره
القدم هي ارتباط كره القدم والمهاره
بالاخلاق يعني هذه في ما كانت ظاهره في
بيلين لذلك باقي اسمه رنان لاخر يوم في
حياته دائما جمع المهاره الفنيه العاليه
الخرافيه مع الاخلاق العاليه دائما نشوفه
في المناسبات دائما
على ارض الملعب او خارج الملعب ويسجل في
العالم احتضانه بيمور بعد مباراه البرازيل
وارجنت انجلترا في كاس العالم 70 باعتبار
ذلك تسديدا للحظه همم من الروح الرياضيه
الصافيه همم لانه
الصوره استحوذت على الاحترام الذي يكون له
لاعبان عظيمان لبعضهم البعض كان لمسات
ونظارات الروح الرياضيه بينهما كلها في
الصوره لا شماته همم لا شماته
من بابي مر اذا هذه هي المعادله هنا ال-
ال- اللاعب الاحترافي مع الاخلاق كما سميت
ذلك استاذ حمزه
التقنيه همم ما ابرز ما ميزه اللاعب
الراحل هو يعتبر تقريبا اللاعب شامل
اللاعب كامل يعني اللاعب يتميز بالتسديدات
بالقدمين لاعب يتميز همم في تسديد بالراس
لاعب قوه المحاورات وفي المهارات الفرديه
هو هو غير شكل كره القدم اللي هي كانت على
القوه وعلى السرعه هو اثقل فيها المهاره
هو اسفل فيها المهاره
ونوعا مال استعراض نوعا ما بدنا استعراض
الدقه همم اصبحت كره القدم فيها نوع من
المتعه هو ضاف لها
المتعه
وظيفه لكره القدم همم الان
فالساعه الثالثه و27 دقيقه مساء بتوقيت
المحلي همم بسبب فشل همم يعني متعدد
الاعضاء وذلك نتج عن اصابته المعروفه
سابقه بسرطان القولون همم وذلك وفقا
للتقرير الطبي اخر ما تريده وكالات
الانباء عن التقرير الطبي الروتر تريد ان
ذلك حصل بناء ان على ذلك اذن وان نشاهد
هذه همم الاخبار العاجله ايضا عن هذه
التقارير الطبيه البرازيليه وفشل الاعضاء
المتعدده هو
ناتج عن مرض القولون الذي يعاني منه سرطان
القولون الذي يعاني منه او كان يعاني منه
بليه همم وما تسبب في النتيجه
بوفاته المهاجم الاشهر في العالم همم
هجمه سرطان القولون ليقضي عليه عن عمر نهز
82 عاما
اللي تترجى الجوهره السوداء كما يصف وكذلك
همم اللعبه الجميله يبقى مصطلحها عن عرشها
همم ولكن هل يسلم ذلك الى احد اخر هذه
الصوره الاخيره التي سجلت له اذا نتابعها
الان وقد نشرتها ابنته على صفحتها على
انستغرام وكنا تابعنا بعض الصور لعائلته
لافراد من عائلته على سرير همم
الراحل في ايامه الاخيره وهم يحاولون ان
يتحدثوا اليه اذا كتبت ابنته نحبك بلا
حدود وارقد بسلام قبل ان نذهب الى هذه
الصور استاذ حمزه ادريس كما سالت قبل قليل
الاستاذ خالد خطابي هل انجب العالم بيلي
اخر حتى الان
همم بصراحه يعني كره القدم ولاده يعني
دائما المقارنات كانت بين بيليه ومارادونا
وحتى وفاتهم كانت في فترات بالنسبه
لمتقاربه فهي خساره كبيره الكره القدم اا
لكن كبيره لسه ما انجبت كره القدم بصراحه
ان كنت يعني رونالدو
يعني كان يملك اا من المهار الكثيره
كمهاجئ لكن بقوه كاس عالم هو في السنه 17
ثلاثه كاس العالم عدد اكثر من 1000 هدف في
كره القدم ارقام خرافيه ما زال الصامته
صعبه جدا همم
صعب جدا خاصه معه تطور كره القدم صعب جدا
انه يلقى تميز على المستوى الفردي كبير
كبير
من الصعب جدا انه نبي معلومات اكثر
وتفاصيل وردود افعال على وفاه ليه بعد
ما نستعرض هذه الصور التي لدينا حول
الموضوع ونعود اليكما استاذ حمزه استاذ
خالد ارجو ان تتقيم معنا
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
الصفحه الثانيه الرسميه على انستغرام
الاتي الالهام والحب عنوان رحله الملك
بيليه الذي
يعني يتوفى بسلام اليوم ايضا تقول هذه
الرساله على صفحه
الرسميه على انستغرام
رسالته اليوم ستصبح ارسا للاجيال المقبله
الحب الحب الحب والحب الى الابد اذا همم
رحيل اسطوره كره القدم بلاي عن عمر 82
عاما الذي بدا اللاعب مع سانتوس في سن
الخامسه عشر والمنتخب البرازيلي بعد ذلك
بسنه خلال مسيرته الدوليه فاز بالثلاث
نهائيات لكاس العالم 58 62
وهو ال- اللاعب الوحيد الذي فعل ذلك اليه
هو الهداف التاريخي للبرازيل برصيد
سبعين هدفا في اثنتين وتسعين مباراه على
مستوى النادي كان افضل هداف في تاريخ
سانتوس برصيد 643 هدفا من 690 مباراه طبعا
في
العصر الذهبي لسانتوس قاد النادي الى كوبا
ليبرتادوريس 62 63 والى كاس الانترنت 62
و63
طبعا كانت دائما لعبته مثيره مياله الى
الاهداف الرائعه كما توصف وليصبح نجما في
العالم اجمع وليقوم بالعديد مع فريقه
بالعديد من الجولات الدوليه من اجل
الاستفاده الكامله من هذه الشعبيه كان في
فتره من الزمن اعلى همم رياضي في العالم
اجرا همم ولكن منذ اعتزاله ظل سفيرا
عالميا لكره القدم بحكم شعبيته الواسعه
وقام بالعديد من شريعه تمثيليه والتجاريه
وظلت الجوائز تنهل عليها وتم تعيينه
الرئيس الفخريه لنيويورك كوزموس طيب نحن
سننتابع الان مع الاستاذ محمد عواد
الاعلامي الرياضي اهلا بك ماذا تعني لك
وفاه
مساء الخير
الرجل الذي الهم كره القدم حاليا كره
القدم القائمه على الارقام القياسيه على
الاشياء الذي لم تتكرر في كره القدم على
الشعبيه والتسويق يعني نحن نتكلم عن كره
القدم الحاليه هي ارقام وشعبيه وتسويق كان
اول من استخدم في التاريخ لتسويق اللعبه
في التاريخ كره القدم كلها لمستوى انه كان
يسافر كما نعلم حول العالم ليرى الناس به
كان هذا هو الارقام حتى اليوم نتكلم عن 50
سنه من الاعتداء له الكره الحقيقيه
استاذ محمد واد يا استاذ خالد خطاط بيه
استاذ حمزه ادريس شكرا جزيلا لكم جميعا
الان
[موسيقى]
قال متحدث باسم الاداره الذاتيه الكرديه
لشمال وشرق سوريا لقمان احمي ان اللقاء
الثلاثيه التي جمع مسؤولين السوريين
واتراكا بحضور روسي في موسكو يهتف الى
منحي انقره مشروعيه للسيطره على الشمال
السوري واضاف ان اللقاءات بين الحكومه
السوريه والنظام التركيه لم تنقطع رغم ما
وصفه بالانتهاكات التركيه تجاه الشعب
السوري وذكر المتحدث لقمان احمي ان هذا
اللقاء الذي جمع بين وزراء دفاع دول
الثلاث لا يخدموا الشعب السوري ولا باي
شكل من الاشكال
ينضم الينا من الحسكه الرئيس المشترك لحزب
الاتحاد الديمقراطيه صالح مسلم اهلا بك
معنا اا سيد صالح في العربيه 360 هل ضحى
بكم الجميع في اللحظه الاخيره
لا نقول انهم ضحوا لانهم لم ااه يعني لم
يكن يحمون او لم يكن في اي وقت من الاوقات
نحن نختلف قليلا نحن نعتمد على على انفسهم
على الاغلب ولا الولايات المتحده
لا الولايات المتحده ايضا يعني نحن هي لم
تخالف وعوده هي لازالت الى جانبنا في
محاربه الارهاب وهذا ما نحن يعني قائمه
لازلنا قائمه
يعني هل ستقبل هل يعني الجميع يتصرف حسب
المصالحه الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
التحالف الدوليه كانت لمحاربه الارهاب
وهذا الواجب لازلنا نحن نقوم به بما يقع
حصلتم في المقابله البعض يعتبر ذلك بانه
استعملتم اعذرني على التعبير من اجل
المحاربه داعش ومن اجل مصالح هذه القوه
جميعا دون ان تحصل على شيء حتى على اعتراف
اوسع مما هو حاليا
لا لا ليس ليس الامور ليست كذلك التقط
مصالح هنا فتعاودنا وكانت مفيده لنا ولاهم
وخلال هذه الفتره اصبح لدينا نوع من الثقه
ولكن هم لم يوعدون بحمايتنا او بتقديم
يعني اي شيء لنا ما عدا ما يخدم محاربه
الارهاب ونحن ملازمنا الصادقين في وعدينا
وفي تعاملنا وحتى اليوم كانت هناك يعني
اعمال مشتركه وعمليات ضد الارهاب في مناطق
مختلفه فيها
الى الان لم يخزنوا يعني حسب ما توافقنا
عليه لم يغسلون نعم سوى طبعا ما ما قلناه
سابقا في عهد ترام حدث بعد
الامور السلبيه يعني
الم تتواصلوا مع الامريكيين فيما يتعلق
بهذا الموضوع ماذا لو سلمت تركيا النظام
فعلا كل المناطق التي تسيطر عليها ماذا
يحصل
الكاميرا
يعني لم لم يظهر احد يحمينا يعني ستقاتلون
النظام
اعترض الولايات المتحده على هذا التقارب
او هذه الحرب التي تشام علينا فهي تعرف
بانها تضر
بمصلحتها تضر بمصلحه محاربه الارهاب لان
مثلا في الفتره الاخيره كما تعلمون من شهر
ونصف كانت هناك جامعه تركيه اعتداءات جويه
وما الى ذلك صحيح علينا ولا زالت هذه
الجاريه مما اضطرت قوتنا الى التصدي لهذا
العدوان اكثر من محاربه الارهاب
يعني انت تهدد جهات التي تدعمكم بانه
باستغناء عنكم يعني استثناء للارهاب مجددا
نعم نعم هذا نحن ما نقوله لان تركيا لا
زالت تحتفظ بجميع اشكال الارهابيين كل
البقايا داعش وبقايا القاعده وبقايا جند
الله كلها هؤلاء الجهاديين السلفيين
المتطرفين
[موسيقى]
النظام المناطق التي تسيطر عليها تركيا
الان
نفضل نحن نريد حل سياسي شامل لكل سوريا
ونحن على الاستعداد لتقديم اي شيء في سبيل
هذا الوقت
من 11 سنه وما في حل في حل يا دوب يوم
بيوم يعني اذا اذا صار في حل يعني اداره
ازمه واداره صراع الان بين ان تبقى تركيا
او ان تنسحب في توافق مع النظام هل
ستقاتلون النظام ام ترحبون باستلامه تلك
المناطق
سيدي نحن لم نقاتل احد نحن لا نفعل الا
دفاع المشروع عن انفسنا عندما يعتدي علينا
احد نحن نرد هذا الاعتداء سواء كان من
تركيا او من غير تركيا نحن لم نعتدي على
احد يعني عندما يحاول يحاول النظام
الاعتداء علينا بما لا يرضى به شعبنا وما
اقمناه هنا في الاداره ذاتيه الديمقراطيه
من مكونات متاخره تحاول الاعتداء علينا لا
شك ان هؤلاء سيدافعون عن انفسهم من هو
عدوكم الان
هادونا الان الذي يعتدي علينا بشكل يومي
هي تركيا
[موسيقى]
والارهاب يعني يجب ان لا نستمعنا التركيه
هي التي تمول هذا الارهاب هي التي تقف
وراءه ما دامت تركيا باقيه بهذه الذهنيه
وبهذه السلطه فل ارهاب سيبقى باقيه يعني
ارهاب لانكم متهمون من قبلها باستهداف
اراضيها وباستهداف المدنيين والامنين من
خلال عمليات الارهابيه
هذا غير صحيح نحن لم نطلق الرصاصه واحده
على تركيا بينما هي التي جنت الاعترافات
التي
اعترفت بها جميع عناصر داعش والاخرون امام
انظار العالم هي كانت تدخل
العوده الى الاجتماع
هل انت مستعد للعوده الى الاجتماعات
الامنيه مع النظام كالتي حصلت من قبل
سوريا
الحوار مع الجميع يعني لا يكاد ينضب من كل
اجابه من اجابتك
لا لا حتى النظام نحن يعني الاداره ذاتيه
الديمقراطيه دقه ابواب النظام وحاولت
الحوار بشكل الاشكال ولكن
اوروبا ما افكارهم نحو الحل السياسي لم
تنضج بعد هم يحاولون فرض ما فرضوه على
مناطق اخرى مثل درعه ومثل
حمص ومناطق اخرى استطاعت استعادته يعني
يريدون الاستسلام وهذا غير ممكن يعني نحن
هنا مكونات في شمال وشرق سوريا الاداره
ذاتيه الديمقراطيه لا يمكن ان تقبل بشروط
الاستسلام التي كانت سابقا النظام لا زال
يعتقد بانه قادر بالوسائل العسكريه الى
العوده الى ما قبل 2011 وهذا غير ممكن
مستحيل
ما اعلم ستكونون قد حصلتموها عندما ترفضون
شروط الاستسلام الحاليه طيله اكثر من 11
سنه من القتال
نحن لدينا مشروع مشروع ديمقراطي وكل من
يتناقش معنا يراه مناسبا ليكون حلا سوريا
مثاليه
الكامله الشامله
[موسيقى]
بهذا الحل الذين نحن نتواصل معهم في ساحل
السوري يطالبون بهذا الحل الجميل يطالب
بالحل اللامركزي الديمقراطي هذا ما نحن
نسعى اليه
شكرا جزيلا لك رئيس المشترك لحزب الاتحاد
الديمقراطيه صالح مسلم من الحسكه تحياتي
اليك
[موسيقى]
قدمت سفيره اسرائيل في فرنسا
في منتصف النهار رساله بالعبريه ارسلتها
الى رئيس الحكومه الجديد وقالت سفيره في
الرساله ان سياسه وتصريحات وزراء الحكومه
ونواياها التشريعيه تتعرض مع مواصفات
اسرائيل
واشار امام جلسه جلسه الكنيسه خلال عرض
اسماء الحكوميه الى اهميه توسيع دائره
السلام مع دول المنطقه
باربع عشان يبقى بقوط سنعمل من اجل ان
تكون اسرائيل قوه عالميه وتحقيقا لهذه
الغايه يجب علينا احباط تطوير الترسانه
النوويه الايرانيه وتاكد من ان ايران لن
تمتلك قنابل ذريه والمهامه الثانيه هي
الاستمرار في توسيع دائره السلام مع دول
المنطقه وانهاء الصراع العربي الاسرائيلي
[موسيقى]
اتحاد كره القدم البرازيليه يقول انبيليه
كان اكثر من اعظم رياضي على مر التاريخ في
ااا بوست على انستغرام اكاد رئيس الامريكي
مع الحكومه الاسرائيليه الجديده برئاسه
لتعزيز المصالح المشتركه وقال ايضا واشنطن
ستواصلوا دعم محل لدولتين وستعارض اي
سياسه تهدد هذا المبدا والعمل مع نتنياهو
على جهود السلام مع الفلسطينيين كما اكد
رئيس الامريكي ان الاداره الامريكيه
ستواصل ايضا العمل
في المنطقه
معنا من واشنطن ناديه البلبيسي مراسله
العربيه اهلا بك معنا ناديه كيف نفهم
الموقف الامريكي من حكومه نتنياهو الجديده
كان على الصعيد على قناه الفلسطينيين او
على صعيد ايران
قال فيه بانه الرئيس يتطلع للعمل مع صديق
قديم يعرفه على مدى عقود وهو نتنياهو لكن
ايضا في نهايه وطبعا هناك تحديات مشتركه
بين الولايات المتحده واسرائيل منها ايران
لكنه اشار في نهايه هذا البيان الى ان
الولايات المتحده تتطلع العمل على بناء
شركات وحالا نزعل العرب الاسرائيلي على
اساس مبدا حل الدولتين هذه هي رساله
بان هناك اختلاف جدري في المواقف
الامريكيه والاسرائيليه بالنسبه لهذه
الاداره هي ترتكز بالدرجه الاساس على ما
بني عليه في السابق وهو حلل الدولتين واا
اشاره ايضا الى ان اي ربما اجراء اسرائيلي
وهنا اشاره ايضا الى توسيع المستوطنات
سيؤثر على حلقه دولتين لكن طبعا كما ح-
يعني اشار اكتر من مسؤول امريكي في الواقع
سواء في الخارجيه او في في البيت الابيض
ليه بان هناك
امتعاد امتعاد من
يمنيه تعتبر الاكثر تطرفا في التاريخ
الاسرائيلي ربما هناك احزاب مثل القوى
اليهوديه والصهيونيه الدينيه التي لا تدعم
حل الدولتان فما بالك نتنيه اصلا الذي لم
يتحدث عن حل الدولتين منذ فتره طويله لكن
ايضا في نفس السياق حسب معلوماتي بانه
الرئيس بيض لا يريد ان يفعل اي اا ربما
مسار تفاوض او العوده للتفاوضات بالنسبه
له الامر ربما انتهى منذ فتره لا يرى بان
هناك اي فرص للنجاح هذه العمليه السلميه
ولدها لا اتوقع ان يكون هناك ربما مبادره
جديده اذا تم انتخاب الرئيس لولايه ثانيه
واذا هذا طبعا ترشح كما تعرف اجازه الان
سيقرر بعد العوده في بدايه العام القادم
اذا كان سترشح لولايه ثانيه اذا ترشحه اذا
فاز ربما نتحدث عن مسار جديد لكن موضوع
ايران ايضا هناك اختلاف جذري بين الولايات
المتحده و بين اسرائيل
عشان طنط تحياتي اليك
في العربيه 360 ايضا بوتينا يدشن طراد
النوويا ويمطر سماء اوكرانيا بالصواريخ
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم معنا من جديد ونتابع واياكم مع
الغاء رحلات الطيران في بلجيكا بعد اضراب
موظف في شركه راين اير ولكن نحن سنتابع في
اخبارنا من افغانستان الان حيث اغلقت
جامعه مورا النسائيه في كابول العاصمه
اغلقت ابوابها بالكامل بعد قرار طالبان
منع تعليم الفتيات وتعتبر جامعه مورا اول
جامعه نسائيه بالكامل من الموظفات والطلبه
والاساتذه وتندرج تحت مؤسسه نورا للتعليم
والتي تضم مدارسه وجامعه ومراكز تدريب
واسكان للطالبات حيث تم افتتاحها عام 2016
وتضم ما يقارب 550 طالبه في مختلف
التخصصات
قال منسق الامم المتحده لشؤون الانسانيه
في افغانستان ان لجنه الطوارئ سترسل وفدا
رفيعه المستوى من اجل اقناع طالبان
بالتراجع عن قراراتها التي تقيد حريه
المراه في البلاد
ستقوم لجنه الطوارئ التابعه للامم المتحده
بزياره الى افغانستان
من اجل العدول عن قرارهم سنحاول ايجاد حل
لهذه المشكله نعتزم ارسال البعثه في
الاسابيع القليله القادمه
معنى من كابول الاستاذ الجامعي دكتور
الشوبير راقب احمد اهلا بك معنا دكتور
شكرا للنظامك الينا كيف استقبلتم خبر منع
الفتيات والنساء من التعلم ومن العمل في
المنظمات الحكوميه ما هو موقفكم الان
اهلا وسهلا ومرحبا بكم
اولا تحياتي لكم ولمشاهدين الكرام
واشكركم جزيل الشكر على هذه الدعوه
والمقابله
والاستقبال كان يعني لم يكن استقبالا جيدا
فهذا القرار يعني له يعني تاثير سلبي جدا
وتداعيات سلبيه كثيره جدا في مجالات
مختلفه في المجالات الاقتصاديه والتعليميه
والاجتماعيه لاجل ذلك رفض الشعب باكمله
رفضا يعني يعني على الكل
ولكن لا يبدو ان طالبان مستعده للتراجع عن
قراراتها هي اا يعني تصدر تصريحات متشدده
جدا بخصوص عدم التراجع عن هذا القرار رغم
المحاولات وضغوط الدوليه هل تعتقد انه
يمكن تقديم شيء همم من قبل المجتمع الدولي
ربما اا او تحت ضغط داخل لكي تتراجع طالبا
عن قرارها
ونحن الان لا نستطيع ان نفتح القول في هذا
المجال لان نحن نرى موقف طالبان في هذا
المجال انهم يعني في الظاهر في الظاهر
انهم لا يتراجعون هذا القرار لان هناك
كانت يعني تجمعات مختلفه جدا ونحن همم
سمعنا
ويعني ما يدور في هذه التجمعات او في
المجلس همم بين طالبان وكذلك الشخصيات في
طالبان هم اكدوا على هذا وصرحوا اننا ابدا
لا نتراجع عن هذا القرار وهذا القرار يعني
قرار نهائيا قالوا كذلك ولكن نحن نرى في
المجتمع وكذلك بين الشعب هناك يعني يعني
هناك رفض كامل جدا وكذلك هناك همم اعبر
الدول الاسلاميه وكذلك الامم المتحده يعني
وخاصه البعثه للامم المتحده في كابول كله
همم هذه المؤسسات وكل هذه الدول يعني
عن غضبها وعن اا يعني رفضها همم اتجاه هذا
القرار حضرتك معترض هل استقلت من التعليم
الجامعي
همم لا انا ما استقلته همم انا ما استقلت
لانني همم ما كنت استاذا للفتيات بل انني
كنتوا استاذا في قسم البنين
بعض بذلك على احتجاجا فقط على الاقل حتى
لو كان يعلم الرجال
همم بس ولكن استاذ يعني ربما سيحدث هذا
فيما بعد ربما يحدث لو مر لو استمر الامر
كذلك ربما يحدث هذا يعني كثيرا يعني كثيرا
من الاساتذه في الجامعات رفضا لهذا القرار
يستقلون هل هذا يشكل ضغطا حقيقيا على
طالبان باعتقادك والعفو انا لم ارد احرازك
ابدا احاول ان اعرف بس حقيقه الوضع كي
يعرف المشاهد العربي ما الذي يحصل يعني
هذا قرارك الشخصي ان كنت تستقيل او لا
ربما لا يكون ايضا في مصلحه الشباب
والرجال ان تستقيل جميعا يعني كي يتوقف
التعليم على كل الاصعده حينها
ايوه يا استاذ يعني ربما يكون ربما يكون
لهذا يعني همم يستقلون الاساتذه من همم
مناصبهم ربما يكون له تاثير ونحن يعني
خاصه في كابول نشاهد بعض الملامح
لهذا العمل لاجل ذلك نحن ناكل يعني سيكون
ان شاء الله له تاثير وكذلك له يعني
تداعيات ايجابيه شكرا جزيلا لك على هذه
المشاركه معنا دكتور شوبير راكب احمد
استاذ الجامعي من كابول تحياتي اليك
نيمار الان يقول بيليه اعطى صوتا للفقراء
للسود
وايضا اعطى يعني وضع البرازيل على الخارطه
ايضا في تصريح على انستغرام على ااا موقعه
او حسابه الشخصيه اذا اخر التصريحات من
نيمار حول وفاه همم
يقول همم
غير كل شيء وحول كره القدم الى فن همم
والى متعه وفقا لتصريح نيمار
قراران اتخذتهما حركه طالبان الاول بمنع
الفتيات من التعليم والاخر بمنعهن من
العمل مع المنظمات الانسانيه الدوليه
اسهاما بموجه غضب عربيه دوليه واسلاميه
المجتمع الدولي يعتبر ان قرارات الحركه
اعاده افغانستان سنوات الى الوراء ليس
اجتماعيا فحسب بل حتى اقتصاديا ومعيشيا اذ
اوقفت العديد من المنظمات الانسانيه
اعمالها في البلاد اذا اوقفت فعلا فهذا
الوقف سيكون له بالغ الاثر على الافغان
الذين يعانون اساسا من اوضاع اقتصاديه
تعيسه كانت تلك المنظمات رافدا ومساعدا
يسد رمق العوز الذي يعصف بالشعب الافغاني
خطوه طالبان اثارت ولا تزال ردود فعل
دوليه عاصفه اذا عقدت الامم المتحده جلسه
احاطه طلبها منسق المنظمه الدوليه للشؤون
الانسانيه
المتحده وقفه او ان الامم المتحده ترت الى
وقف بعض البرامج والمساعدات في افغانستان
مؤقتا كرد على طالبان هو الذي اعلن وحذر
من ان العديد من الانشطه الاخرى ستتوقف
على الارجح المنسق الاممي اضاف في بيان ان
الامم المتحده لا يمكنها تجاهل القيود
التشغيليه التي تواجه المجتمع الانساني في
افغانستان مشيرا الى ان المنظمه الدوليه
ستسعى لمواصله الانشطه المنقذه للحياه
[موسيقى]
بدورها دعت مجموعه السبع حركه طالبان الى
الالغاء العاجل لحظر عمل النساء في
المنظمات غير الحكوميه وفق ما جاء في بيان
المشترك نشرته وزاره الخارجيه البريطانيه
بشده لان امر طالبان متهور والخطير بمنع
الموظفات النساء من العمل في المنظمات غير
الحكوميه الوطنيه
ورفاهيه الشعب الافغاني خصوصا النساء
والفتيات
عربيا اتخذت غالبيه الدول الموقفا حازما
من قرارات طالبان مواقف كررها بشده الامين
العام لمنظمه التعاون الاسلاميه حسين
ابراهيم الذي دعا الى موقف جماعي بشان
قرار طالبان منع الفتيات من التعليم
الجامعي طه دعم مجمع الفقه الاسلامي
الدوليه الى حشد موقف من الم ياتي كافه
والعلماء المسلمين من قرار طالبان ضد
تعليم الفتيات وصفا القرار بانه يعتبر
احدث التحديات التي يواجهها المجمع وشدد
طه على اولويه الملف الافغاني في اجنده
عمل المنظمه والمجمع مشيرا الى ان قرار
طالبان لا يستند الى نصوص في الشريعه
الاسلاميه
المتحدث باسمي اتحاد الجامعه الخاصه في
افغانستان محمد كريم مصير قال ان ربع
الجامعات الخاصه في افغانستان تواجه خطر
الاغلاق بسبب الحظر المفروض على الطالبات
من قبل حكومه طالبان
[موسيقى]
شهيد الرئيس
في تطوير القوات البحريه امر مهم وحيويه
لان روسيا في السنوات المقبله
افاد مراسل العربيه باستهداف واسع نطاقته
على العاصمه الاوكرانيه كاف نتج عنه ثلاث
اصابات مع تدمير العديد من المنازل
الاوضاع كما تشاهد امامك في الصوره
استهداف واسع النطاق طالا العاصمه
الاوكرانيه كيف وعدد كبير من المدن هنا
امامنا في الشاشه همم الشرطه الادله
الجنائيه تقوم بجمع الادله من مكان وقوع
الانفجار في منطقه بورنشي هذه المنطقه هذه
القريه التي تقع في ضواحي العاصمه اكيد
الاستهداف همم يعني نتيجته دمر عدد من
المنازل لم تسجل همم
ولكن هنالك ثلاثه اصابات نقل الاشخاص
المصابين من هنا الى العاصمه الى داخل
المدينه لتلقي الرعايه الصحيه
في العربيه 360 ايضا في ايران استقاله
محافظ البنك المركزي الايراني بعد انخفاض
تاريخي للعمله
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد بعد ان هوت العمله
الايرانيه استقال محافظ البنك المركزي
الايرانيه علي صالح عبادي بعد انخفاض
تاريخي للعمله اعلام النظام الايراني ذكر
ان حكومه الرئيس ابراهيم الرئيسي قبلت
استقاله ابادي وعينت محمد
محافظه جديده للبنك المركزي
رفعت حصيله ضحايا العاصفه الثلجيه التي
تشهدها ولايه نيويورك الامريكيه لتبلغ
واحدا 61 قتيلا فيما رشحت فرق الطوارئ
الرقم للارتفاع مجددا مع انحسار الثلوج في
غضون ذلك اكد عمده بطل وانا المدينه
الواقعه على الحدود الكنديه احسن وحدها 34
قتيلا فيما لا تزال اكثر من 1000 عائله من
دوني كهرباء
صوره اليوم في العربيه 360 من العاصمه
الاوكرانيه كاف والقذف الروسي الذي لم
يبقي من هذا المنزل لم يبقي الا ظله بدات
في عام 22 الحرب في اوكرانيا منتهى العام
هو الحرب
فيديو اليوم من مدينه طبربورده الروسيه
على الحدود مع اوكرانيا حيث وصل الى هناك
سانتا كلوزر روسي على ظهري مدرعه وتجول
سانتا بالاحياء في عربته المصفحه وتفاعل
مع الجنود في احدى الغباء
شكرا على متابعتكم العربيه 360 باخبارها
وملفاتها ولكن اخبار الساعه لا تنقطع
تتابع الان مع عادل عيدان واخبار الساعه
عادل مساء الخير ماذا لديك مساء النور
طاهر بالتاكيد سنتعرف على الهديه التي
قدمت لتركيا في الشمال وكذلك لدينا التخوف
الفلسطيني من الحكومه الاسرائيليه
وايضا موسكو ستكون ضمن هذه النشره ووفاه
الاسطوره بيليه
شكرا جزيلا لك عادل
[موسيقى]